We now move to a new topic--
conditioning.
Every probabilistic concept or
probabilistic fact has a
conditional counterpart.
As we have seen before, we can
start with a probabilistic
model and some initial
probabilities.
But then if we are told that
the certain event has
occurred, we can revise our
model and consider conditional
probabilities that take into
account the available
information.
But as a consequence, the
probabilities associated with
any given random variable will
also have to be revised.
So a PMF will have to be changed
to a conditional PMF.
Let us see what is involved.
Consider a random variable X
with some given PMF, whose
values, of course, sum
to 1, as must be true
for any valid PMF.
We are then told that a certain
event, A, has occurred.
In that case, the event
that X is equal to--
little x--
will now have a conditional
probability of this form.
We will use this notation here
to denote the conditional
probability that the random
variable takes the
value little x.
Notice that the subscripts are
used to indicate what we're
talking about.
In this case, we are talking
about the random variable X in
a model where event A is
known to have occurred.
Of course, for this conditional
probability to be
well defined, we will have to
assume that the probability of
A is positive.
This conditional PMF is like an
ordinary PMF, except that
it applies to a new or revised
conditional model.
As such, its entries
must also sum to 1.
Now the random variable X has
a certain mean, expected
value, which is defined
the usual way.
In the conditional model, the
random variable X will also
have a mean.
It is called the conditional
mean or the conditional
expectation.
And it is defined the same way
as in the original case,
except that now the calculation
involves the
conditional probabilities,
or the conditional PMF.
Finally, as we discussed some
time ago, a conditional
probability model is just
another probability model,
except that it applies
to a new situation.
So any fact about probability
models--
any theorem that we derive--
must remain true in the
conditional model as well.
As an example, the expected
value rule will have to remain
true in the conditional model,
except that, of course, in the
conditional model, we will have
to use the conditional
probabilities instead of the
original probabilities.
So to summarize, conditional
models and conditional PMFs
are just like ordinary models
and ordinary PMFs, except that
probabilities are replaced
throughout by conditional
probabilities.
Let us now look at an example.
Consider a random variable,
which in this case, is
uniform, takes values
from 1 up to 4.
So each one of the possible
values has
probability 1 over 4.
For this random variable, we
can calculate the expected
value, which by symmetry is
going to be the midpoint.
So it is equal to 2 and 1/2.
We can also calculate
the variance.
And here we can apply
the formula that we
have derived earlier--
1/2 times b minus a times
b minus a plus 2.
And in this case, it's 1 over 12
times b minus a is 4 minus
1, which is 3.
And the next term is 5.
And after we simplify,
this is 5 over 4.
Suppose that now somebody tells
us that event A has
occurred, where event A is that
the random variable X
takes values in the
range 2, 3, 4.
What happens now?
What is the conditional PMF?
In the conditional model, we are
told that the value of 1
did not occur, so this
probability is going to be 0.
The other three values
are still possible.
What are their conditional
probabilities?
Well, these three values had
equal probabilities in the
original model, so they should
have equal probabilities in
the conditional model as well.
And in order for probabilities
to sum to 1, of course, these
probabilities will
have to be 1/3.
So this is the conditional PMF
of our random variable, given
this new or additional
information about the outcome.
The expected value of the
random variable X in the
conditional universe--
that is, the conditional
expectation--
is just the ordinary expectation
but applied to the
conditional model.
In this conditional model, by
symmetry, the expected value
will have to be 3, the midpoint
of the distribution.
And we can also calculate the
conditional variance.
This is a notation that we have
not yet defined, but at
this point, it should
be self-explanatory.
It is just the variance of
X but calculated in the
conditional model using
conditional probabilities.
We can calculate this variance
using once more the formula
for the variance of a uniform
distribution, but we can also
do it directly.
So the variance is the expected
value of the squared
distance from the mean.
So with probability 1/3, our
random variable will take a
value of 4, which is one unit
apart from the mean, or more
explicitly, we have this term.
With probability 1/3,
our random variable
takes a value of 3.
And with probability 1/3, our
random variable takes the
value of 2.
This term is 0.
This is 1 times 1/3.
From here we get another
1 times 1/3.
So adding up, we obtain that
the variance is 2/3.
Notice that the variance in
the conditional model is
smaller than the variance that
we had in the original model.
And this makes sense.
In the conditional model, there
is less uncertainty than
there used to be in the
original model.
And this translates into a
reduction in the variance.
To conclude, there is nothing
really different when we deal
with conditional PMFs,
conditional expectations, and
conditional variances.
They are just like the ordinary
PMFs, expectations,
and variances, except that we
have to use the conditional
probabilities throughout
instead of the original
probabilities.